lieblingsessen pizza-bäcker
lieblingsfarbe war schwierig rot-grün
mittel aquamarine blau traumberuf
astronaut natürlich aber reichen meine
kognitiven fähigkeiten später aus unter
stetigem druck auf konstant hohem niveau
zu performen
vielleicht nehme ich lieber was weniger
anspruchsvolles youtube sowie die jungs
von wcc so oder so ähnlich kennt das
doch bestimmt jeder wer wollte als kind
nicht gerne astronaut werden
zugegeben die meisten haben die chance
leider nie bekommen aber vielleicht seid
ihr diesen traum jetzt gerade so nah wie
nie zuvor
denn genau ab heute ist es soweit ab dem
31 märz 2021 sucht die esa das erste mal
seit 2008 wieder nach neuen
astronautinnen und astronauten was ihr
für die bewerbung alles mitbringen
müssen wie ihr euch am besten
vorbereitet und wie hoch ihre chancen
tatsächlich sind das erzähle ich euch
heute bei doktor watson und wer weiss
hätte mein junges naives ich dieses
video damals gesehen dann wäre
vielleicht alles ganz anders gekommen
dann würde ich jetzt mit etwas glück
durch die endlosen weiten des weltraums
schweben
ach ja mein lieblingstier giraffe als
wir glauben
zum ersten mal seit 2008 wird die
europäische raumfahrtagentur esa
neue astronautinnen und astronauten
rekrutieren letztendlich möchte in der
lage sein mit menschlichen besatzung zum
mars zu fliegen
ok fangen wir mal ganz von vorne an dein
traum war es schon immer als astronautin
oder astronaut unsere erde aus dem
weltall zu betrachten dann hält dich
jetzt im grunde genommen nichts mehr
davon ab außer ein paar kleinen
formalitäten vielleicht denn um nicht
bei der esa bewerben zu können brauchst
du folgendes die staatsbürgerschaft
eines eu mitgliedstaats mindestens einen
master in naturwissenschaften mathematik
medizin ingenieurwesen oder it und noch
dazu mindestens drei jahre
berufserfahrung in einem dieser
fachbereiche
dazu musst du noch fließend englisch
sprechen und mindestens eine weitere
fremdsprache sehr gut beherrschen und am
ende brauchst du dann auch noch von
einem flug mediziner eine ausgestellte
medizinische bescheinigung über
allgemein gute gesundheit und schon kann
es losgehen
wem das jetzt so schnell ging der kann
sich alles natürlich nochmal in ruhe auf
der für die bewerbung eingerichteten
webseite der esa ansehen den link findet
ihr unten in der video beschreibung
übrigens direkt über dem link zu unserer
petri an seite wo wir uns supporten
könnt damit wir weiter regelmäßig videos
wiegt dieses hier produzieren können
danke so sollte das alles auf dich zu
treffen dann herzlichen glückwunsch du
kannst dich bei der esa bewerben
für alle die jetzt zwar hochmotiviert
aber vielleicht noch nicht ganz soweit
sind keine sorge für euch ist die reise
hier noch nicht zu ende wir trotzdem
noch zu esa kommen könnt das verrate ich
euch gleich treffen aber die formalen
kriterien schon mal auf dich zu dann
wird es zeit deine bewerbung zu
schreiben dazu hast du von heute dem 31
märz bis zum 28
mai diesen jahres zeit wir stehen ganz
klassisch einen lebenslauf und ein
motivationsschreiben auf den plan und
ein von der esa entworfener fragebogen
ist dann auch noch mit entscheidend
dafür ob du die erste runde der
bewerbung über stehst jennifer nur an
hat uns außerdem erzählt was man
menschlich mitbringen sollte wenn man
sich bewerben will
sie koordiniert im direktorat für
bemannte und robotische raumfahrt bei
der esa die wissenschaft unter
weltraumbedingungen dabei ist sie unter
anderem für die planung von einsätzen
auf der iss verantwortlich und hat ganz
viel kontakt zu den astronautinnen und
astronauten im orbit kurz gesagt eine
sehr coole frau
man muss vor allem in der lage sein als
teil von einem interkulturellen und
interdisziplinären team zu arbeiten und
unter druck die ruhe bewahren zu können
das ist sehr sehr wichtig ok also man
sollte am besten nicht auf den kopf
gefallen sein
aber wie sieht es denn mit den
körperlichen voraussetzungen aus unsere
astronauten sehen alle körperlich topfit
und es hilft schon bevor man astronaut
wird sie sportlich zu betätigen fit zu
sein viel an die frische luft zu gehen
und es hilft auch komplexe schwierige
aufgaben motorische fähigkeiten zu üben
alles klar aber es kann ja nicht jeder
einfach so laufen gehen um sich fit zu
halten zum beispiel menschen die von
geburt an oder durch einen unfall mit
einer körperlichen behinderung leben
sie konnten sich deshalb bisher leider
gar nicht als astronautin oder astronaut
bewerben und genau das soll sich nun
ändern
zum ersten mal in der geschichte der
raumfahrt gibt es nicht nur einen
astronauten programm sondern auch ein
paar astronauten programm
hier suchte er gezielt nach menschen mit
einer körperlichen behinderung die ins
weltall wollen also in dem fall suchen
wir menschen die alle psychologischen
kognitiven technischen und beruflichen
voraussetzungen für meine astronauten
laufbahn erfüllen wir haben bestimmte
körperliche einschränkungen aufgrund
derer sie normalerweise nicht als
astronautin oder als astronaut
ausgewählt werden würden
wegen der einschränkungen zum beispiel
in zusammenhang mit den systemen oder
mit den geräten geben euro-raum
verwendet werden
wir sind aber bereit in die notwendigen
anpassungen von diesen geräten von
diesen systemen zu investieren um einen
solch exzellent qualifizierten menschen
zu ermöglichen cool mitglied einer
sicheren unmögliche mission zu sein
ich persönlich finde das mega wichtig
und sehr sehr cool von der esa und
obwohl in dieser ausschreibung erst mal
nur sehr bestimmte körperliche
behinderungen mit eingeschlossen sind
hoffe ich dass wir in zukunft immer mehr
inklusion in der raumfahrt und auch
generell in der wissenschaft sehen
werden also gut du hast nun alle
unterlagen für das astro oder das paar
astronauten programm eingereicht und
eine überzeugende bewerbung abgegeben
mit etwas glück würdest du noch ein
klein bisschen wartezeit für die nächste
runde ausgewählt
jetzt geht es in die sogenannten
screenings also die ersten gespräche
insgesamt gibt es übrigens acht
verschiedene stufen des auswahlprozesses
das screening findet von mai bis juni
2021 statt
dann folgen von juli bis november
psychologische tests und im ersten teil
2022 praktische und psychologische tests
um die körperlichen und mentalen
fähigkeiten zu messen
danach kommt nochmal eine abschließende
medizinische überprüfung und wenn du
dann noch im spiel bist dann folgen die
ersten gespräche von zwei
interviewrunden mit der obersten riege
der esa diese gespräche werden im juli
und september nächstes jahr stattfinden
tja und dann ist es im oktober 2022 auch
endlich soweit in einer pressekonferenz
werden die sechs neuen sogenannten
karriere astronautinnen und astronauten
bekannt gegeben
und wenn du deinen namen hörst dann hast
du es geschafft dann bist du astronauten
oder astronaut bei der europäischen
raumfahrt-agentur herzlichen glückwunsch
okay zugegeben anderthalb jahre klingen
nach einem ziemlich langen prozess einer
menge aufwand und vor allem viel stress
an starker konkurrenz wird es
wahrscheinlich auch nicht mangeln
2008 haben sich zum beispiel insgesamt
8400 13 menschen beworben von denen nur
sechs genommen wurden
wie stellt man sich also am besten auf
gesuch ein auswahlverfahren ein
also ich habe mit vielen astronauten
zwischenzeit geredet alle sagen man soll
liegt verbissen an die sache
ran gehen sondern ja entspannt und ja
alle geben dann ehrliche ehrlich zu dass
sie niemals gedacht hätten so weit zu
kommen und haben sich über jede weitere
stufe diese diese geschafft haben
gefreut und haben das auch genossen an
diesen auswahlprozessen an den
verschiedenen aufgaben teilzunehmen
leider hatte die esa in der
vergangenheit schon das problem dass vor
allem frauen der ansicht waren nicht für
den beruf der astronauten geeignet zu
sein
2008 wurden zum beispiel nur rund einen
sechstel aller bewerbungen von frauen
eingereicht von denen hat es dann
instrumente cristoforetti tatsächlich
auch geschafft als eine von sechs
ausgewählt zu werden
in der theorie sind die chancen also für
qualifizierte frauen genauso hoch wie
für männer und in der praxis gilt das
laut der esa sowieso für alle
deswegen begrüßen wir ausdrücklich
bewerbungen von allen qualifizierten
kandidatinnen und kandidaten unabhängig
von geschlecht ethnische zugehörigkeit
glauben alter und anderen eigenschaften
und gerade für diese esa astronauten
auswahl möchten besonders frank nur zu
ermutigen sich zu bewerben
dann wir mehr geschlechterverteilung in
unserem astronauten kader haben möchten
das ganze interview mit jennifer ist
übrigens knapp eine dreiviertel stunde
lang und mega interessant geworden
wer mehr darüber erfahren möchte was
astronautinnen und astronauten
eigentlich so treiben wenn sie gerade
nicht im weltall sind und welche neuen
einsatzgebiete auf zukünftige
generationen zu kommen könnten
der kann gerne auf kathrin unterstützen
schon ab einem euro pro monat habt ihr
die möglichkeit dieses und viele weitere
experten interviews in kompletter länge
zu gucken und unterstützt gleichzeitig
auch noch unseren kanal dabei weitere
videos wie dieses hier in zukunft zu
machen
dankeschön
ok halten wir also mal fest wer
astronauten oder astronaut werden will
muss keine superkräfte haben klar die
notwendigen formalien setzen voraus dass
man sich schon ein paar jahre mit
forschung und wissenschaft
auseinandergesetzt hat aber es braucht
eben keine zwei doktortitel oder einen
gewonnenen ironman um sich bewerben zu
können
auch alexander gerst und samantha
cristoforetti ermutigen alle die den
traum haben einmal im weltall zu fliegen
dazu sich zu bewerben
sie selbst haben laut eigener aussage
nämlich am aller wenigsten damit
gerechnet tatsächlich genommen zu werden
ich bin auch nicht davon ausgegangen
dass gibt nehmen würden aber ich dachte
das bin ich meinen 80 jährigen selbst
schuldig dass ich in meinem leben still
sitzen kann mit meinen enkelkindern sage
ich habe mich wenigstens einmal geworden
wo es mal versuchen wirklich an
am meisten erstaunt dass angenommen
wurde
der hauptpreis ist natürlich ein flug in
der rakete zur internationalen
raumstation oder oder vielleicht sogar
zum mond das klingt ja alles schön und
gut aber jetzt suchen wahrscheinlich
schon einige von euch wo bekomme ich
möglichst schnell und günstig einen
master her
oder wie kann ich in einem monat zwei
fremdsprachen lernen dazu direkt macht
euch keinen stress sollte die im moment
noch in der schule sein oder vielleicht
gerade im studium dann könnt ihr jetzt
der perfekte zeitpunkt sein und mit der
vorbereitung für die nächste
bewerbungsrunde zu beginnen ein termin
steht natürlich noch nicht fest aber in
knapp zehn jahren könnte es sehr
wahrscheinlich wieder so weit sein
wir ermutigen alle die jetzt noch zu
jung sind sich ihnen
naturwissenschaftliche oder ingenieurs
fachbereiche zugegeben
daher gehen der ausbildung zu machen und
berufserfahrungen zu sammeln und wer
weiß vielleicht ist dann der richtige
zeitpunkt in den zehn jahren da um sich
dann zu bewerben generell kann ich auch
nur noch mal betonen macht das wofür ihr
brennt egal ob ihren die wissenschaft
oder den profisport oder die filmbranche
volt versucht es auch wenn es so scheint
als würde dir nicht ins muster passen
bleibt dran auch wenn es zwischendurch
mal schwierig wird und selbst wenn es
nicht klappt könnt ihr euch nicht
vorwerfen es nicht wenigstens versucht
zu haben
am ende habe ich auf jeden fall etwas
neues über euch selber und eure
fähigkeiten gelernt einen link zur
bewertungsseite der esa findet ihr wie
gesagt unten in der wie die beschreibung
ist es der allererste link also es kann
keiner behaupten er oder sie hätte es
nicht gefunden
es gibt keine ausreden eure träume nicht
zu verfolgen und wenn es mit der
astronauten laufbahn nicht klappen
sollte
die esa bietet natürlich auch eine menge
anderer stelle zum beispiel könnt ihr
auch als ingenieurin an
raketentechnologie arbeiten oder im
mission control center sitzen um das
weltall zu erforschen muss man nicht ins
weltall fliegen vielen dank an dieser
stelle auch noch mal an die esa und vor
allem an jennifer nur an für das
ausführliche interview
wenn euch das jetzt in kompletter länge
ansehen wollt wie gesagt wir konnten
leider nicht alles mit reinnehmen in
dieses video hier dann könnt ihr das
auch bachelor tun und uns gleichzeitig
unterstützen niemanden dank fürs
zuschauen
falls ihr tatsächlich astronaut oder
astronauten werden sollte dann bitte
gebt uns ein interview wenn ihr auf der
ss seid und bleibt wie immer neugierig